hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play dead
space 3 okay we just got done with
conning-tower and we're on our way to
repair a shuttle to try to get our
friends off of this base and I apologize
in advance if I start coughing because I
seem to have something stuck in my
throat
but I will try to persevere anyway we
just got done the checkpoint system in
this game is a little wonky it started
me back before I got on the tram at all
so I had to fight my way through on the
two guys and I'm not even sure if I kept
all the scrap metal and stuff that I
found from the conning tower I think I
did but I'm not exactly sure anyway
I'm well stocked well supplied I've got
tons of stuff engineering and repair oh
this looks good anyway I've got tons of
stuff ready for upgrades oh this has got
a nice feel to the place anyway I also
stopped by a bench and made two more
torque bars
ah-ha-ha-ha-ha ostrich laughs anyway
there's a there's a dude here but
there's also I hero a thing somewhere
over here actually right here
alright here okay and you guys told me
that I should use a scrap Bora bought
every chance I get so I'm gonna start
doing that from now on bad for now let
us get our way military engine alright
and put this mechanical keyboard to good
use well what do we got mo mo mo mo
scrap metal nothing too exciting just
some basic supplies but for how much it
cost to make a torque bar it's pretty
well worth it it's not equivalent to a
power node anymore it's just basically
nothing alright anyway call yeah
ah not you your dick what are you doing
here I just danced with you oh I saw
something doors were opening ha ha ha
not today that guy's gonna be a pain in
my ass for this whole duration of the
ship holy balls and out that I don't
appreciate a good challenge I do love
this gun this gun is everything I could
have possibly imagined ha ha yeah
pressurize the cabin come on the repair
austell move there we go all right not
getting me around if I can build a
remote relay I can plant it on the hall
all right sounds good I guess call that
go here scope out some more stiff I need
to call craft a remote relay how do I do
that do I do that at a bench or
something
I found 0 3 shuttle pieces I need to
make them okay whatever I need to get
some stuff to make some stuff basically
pretty much errand material which
everyone knows Isaac Clarke far too good
Oh what am I doing here okay I need to
get to the other side I'm guessing hey
let's see a multi-axis gondola is it the
gondola the thing in the Italian Canal
saloon
house or Nami or normal trabajo I don't
speak Italian but I'm pretty sure I was
close any Italians watching I'm pretty
close right house right on there I
thought right stays his support and what
does that do I wonder I wonder okay let
me at the bench thank you I need to make
relays uh additional parts required
remote circuit board radio controller
and Ras locator module okay
stasis support I want to find what this
stasis support is I've already got an
electrical charge on this but health
packs consumed by cell fault or your
partner okay that doesn't help me
because I am playing zone and okay all
right so obviously I need to find some
important gear from around the whole
area and I've actually got a plethora of
med packs almost too many I'm at
actually I'm gonna stuff I'm gonna stuff
some in the safe until I can get back to
it because I don't want to run out of
inventory because I know okay yeah I
know I need them can I carry on no
that's not where I went okay
just need a stuff agent no gimme dad you
dick guy you dick
listen to my command you obey me for a
duh you obey Isaac Clark Rd Clark knows
what's best fraud to Clark alright
whatever let's go down that seems to be
the only place that I need to go now
anybody else wanna step you you're just
a shell of your former self done just
like me
duh oh hell oh here we go oh no no screw
you a-holes uh-uh not today
give me that thing ah
I can do that too it's another med pack
man med packs are just raining out of
the skies now that I'm getting into the
swing of things
hard hard is not all that hard okay
sup bro wow you do not get that close to
me I don't even let my friends get that
close to me hello cuz there's some
serious stuff going down on the other
side there I need to find the other
materials here's one whoa okay something
is going on over there that's a party
that I was not invited to Wow nice
jumper ahem
oh no no real of real of bat-time [ __ ]
worst time to reload holy balls
you rip your [ __ ] tail off her head I
guess miss there we go
oh man absolute worst time out huh oh
come on there we go
Jesus Connor need to stomp the goodies
out of you it's like a pinata
Hey okay so I got two of the things oh I
see the other ones on the other side duh
duh isla Isaac Clark's a little slow on
the pickup but Isaac Clark got it okay
so I got two of them on today we're
gonna waste time with the bench into up
come on
suck down a shotgun run [ __ ] these guys
are all over the place don't calm the
[ __ ] down buddy
how did I miss that I was right there oh
no wait it's down below wait a minute
wait whoa whoa how do I get to it it's
down there I need to okay all right here
we go I'm an idiot I got it I got it I
got it
wait what I know this isn't right either
how the balls don't okay all right oh
there must be another slip just like
that one over here yeah there it is
there it is I'm an idiot yeah Isaac
Clark's a little slow but that's okay
everybody likes Isaac Clark
except for Ellie Oh her big boobs I miss
him so much I mean her
okay I'm little concerned about like
they're just I hear these noises from
all around me and I'm worried they're
just gonna pop out of a vent and I'm
gonna be so boned Hey ah no no no no
where are you where are you where are
you there you are don't even try it
these a-holes they're not even gonna
give me a second to be at the bench at
this rate just shut up
know it up give me over there thank you
I don't want any is anyone over here
waiting for me probably probably okay
just give me two seconds of hey Dwight
can I do this
AHA I knew I couldn't I would have been
blown up it's like a frickin nightmare
in here Jesus let's just go let's just
go let's just go man go go go go come on
do it do it do it do it do it do it do
it do it do it do it do it do do do
cross-table there we go I'm done I'm out
of here
let's go man holy balls that is like a
frigging thing I've seen so far in this
game
good God I mean look let me in or let me
on I don't know what I'm doing I'm
putting these there we going
okay all right then you do that I'll be
here waiting okay it's out of fuel of
course it is fueling station on the
upper floor here okay all right let's
shut 'el you try restarting after that I
like how Isaac's just totally calm
everything's going to hell there's
basically a choir of demons screaming
all around him and he couldn't give two
shits he's just like man everyday
business for me dumb Isaac luck far too
badass to be concerned
see they shut up oh you did not
so it's you two that were causing the
ruckus hey love is gone God is just too
Pro right let's make some progress here
makin bacon scavengers Bob waiting at
the bench dammit
I just passed the bench all right I got
time I want to have that scavenger Bob
because I want to be able to upgrade my
suit because I need a lot of resources
to upgrade my suit I mean I've done
quite a few already but resources are a
bit of a scarce commodity here let's go
let's go there are monsters around it's
just like the first dead space the
waiting for the store was so slow what a
ration seals I have no idea what that is
okay out out out out out out I know how
to go are you kidding me you're giving
me the tutorial did I hit the tutorial
button somehow am i hitting the tutorial
button somehow yes I want to skip all I
hit tab I'm an idiot what I know how to
use so bench come on remove that after
I've seen it once alright anyway once
again I'm blaming the game for my own
dumb mistakes okay this seems to be one
over ah [ __ ] hell you gotta be
kidding me
I'm not going back [ __ ] it I'll get the
next one or maybe it's up here could be
never know
I hear it it is up here huh who's there
I hear you Fandango and gingo bingo flam
Agha last ah I don't know I'm speaking
gibberish now the markers getting to me
I'm speaking in tongues I can't even
speak English why would I be able to
speak in tongues going up here I'll
ignore him for now I'll meet him later
catch you later buddy
you can you can ask me a question all
right what do we got here
refuel that [ __ ] Hey look it's an old
power note box but it doesn't have a
power note in it it is there someone out
there or what are you just [ __ ] with
me yeah oh there was a clip thingy rate
of fire damage hell's to the yeah refuel
that [ __ ] oh it is roof no it's not
refueling who is out there there is
someone out there and I do not
appreciate this mind games are not happy
fun times killing Necromorphs is happy
fun times where Bob Foley walls Jesus
and [ __ ] you Jesus Christ
okay who's goofing all over the place
Jesus lead back to your room man manual
connection required oh wow
it's one hell of a keynesian thing no no
chop it destroyed
shotgun oh hello
you're still ugly come at me bread come
at me bran hey to prowl to prowl ah jeez
those ones are freaky because they're
not actually necrobook they look more
like zombies and anything I mean
Necromorphs I'm practically used to by
now but those things are just weird
that's more like it
okay I'm initiating a testify of the
shuttles engine bay cover this could get
hot is this how I'm gonna kill the big
guy again I did it before I can do it
again
keep it bloody ancient techno Oh Oh God
Isaac I think I just started the launch
sequence and I don't know how to stop it
way to go Ellie Wow oh [ __ ] to a crisp
okay it's gonna roast me to a crypt I
understood that tremor go this way
hahaha I need to get out of here before
I roast to crisp dodge bad duh
even Isaac Clarke knows that's bad for
my health alright screw the floor Oh God
let's go let's go let's go
excuse me buddy little busy here
go get roasted get rooted you too buddy
whoa what what you're just you're okay
with all that ah excuse me gotta go
gotta go gotta go gotta go gotta go now
now I gotta go
way to go Ellie you really are trying to
kill me couldn't handle that I was all
man's chick the only way she's gonna
forget is by killing me I don't know
okay hi guys birthday screw you buddy
calling the cargo lift the not a damn
thing you can do about it
thank you please die in hell there mate
I'm going up you stay down there in burn
[ __ ] you burn [ __ ]
okay now as we carry on to where we go
haha
buzzer dies a clerk on fire oh hello
Stratus dig up on me ain't gonna work oh
oh no go out fire thank you Jesus
how do I get out of here all down now
there's to you where do I go what knock
ah ah man oh I see okay I'm an idiot
ah you gotta be joking me you um [ __ ]
almost out of this current clip [ __ ]
come on thatís just get to there
to the point open [ __ ]
alright I'll check the gears check the
gears it's gonna pop the hood on the old
end in there he's an engineer I don't
know any better
these sons of [ __ ] are all over me
where am I going I'm going in a big
convoluted circle that's what I'm doing
I need a guide ha ha ha
all right down I go fire please go away
fire further thank you funny thank you
fire no okay this looks bad I pass this
reminds me of something I [ __ ] pass
in hell damn it you put it out on one
side starting on the other I thought
good flight systems nominal system check
him oh good way to go Ellie come on
Ellie what the [ __ ]
Jesus it's okay she has gigantic boobs
she can get away with a lot
that was not good looks like military
ordinance I'm gonna try it
guren explosion oh god oh god now you
care about me before lighting me on fire
yeah that's good okay ah now this is
what Isaac Clark and talking about stop
you're gonna screw yourself [ __ ] robbed
I forget obliterated him
no now now now i frickin destroyed them
what are their uber Moore's by the Dozen
now
now this is what I like God I
I like how exploding barrels can just go
right into the gears and nothing bad
happens at all
now you down and I like how the
Necromorphs all fall directly in front
of me and not buy ya stupid [ __ ] and now
the gears are just provided
oh hey I'm helping you Isaac oh uh I
wasn't so bad
better than being in the fires I guess
you did it yeah screw you everybody
let's get the docking bay ready to
receive the shuttle Isaac
we'll see you when you get back ah how
about you screw up how about all of you
just try to imagine what just happened
to me and what I've done
to help you all are [ __ ] I saw her
oh it's Z to orient to ground I've been
trying to wonder what that was this
entire time those mines
that's not good there's probably some
useful scrap around here but um yeah I'm
not gonna waste any time and those might
seem to be getting close to me ah ah oh
man I was I was mildly startling Give Me
Mine you need to back the feck array
thank you wait what's is that oh that's
that's Salvage but I don't have any I
need to I need to hurry up before I run
out of here I mean I've got plenty of
air but I am neither just carry on a
little bit quicker than I am
I can't believe that Isaac didn't say
anything in response to what what they
were law like yeah you did are they
gonna go you're the best he's just like
okay I guess this is my life now running
stupid errands for everybody here more
oxygen thank you okay I guess I'm going
down down and about oh by the way as a
side note I just finally watched the
newest episode of of Walking Dead which
is one of my new favorite shows or it
has been my favorite show for a while
but don't god I love it anyway that was
just me I just popped into my head had
to say it okay what am I doing here what
am I doing here what am i doing know
what imma do what M I do
here what am i doing what am i doing
scavenger Bob waiting for bench yeah
that doesn't help me here what am I uh
so how's the shell look yeah this thing
needs more than plating it's missing the
port engine
Oh will write me the Greely it could be
a shuttle we should check it out but
really isn't that wooden block oh here
we go engine duty oh yeah like see I'm
not asking you to do jumping jacks then
get moving
alright Rosen I'll meet you there
whatever whatever Brit
whatever I'm an angsty teen in your ear
you're just in a hole or he was a cop
that was the captain right I have no
idea who that was
let's get out of here to the Greeley
wasn't that that was the optional
mission wasn't it thought so I guess I
guess I could have piled on the optional
mission with that one like guess what do
I know
I'm just Isaac Clark I don't do it I
everybody tell me and the way we go I
still think that this whole space
exploration thing is really cool I mean
a lot of games don't touch on space
exploration like it seems like all the
games for the past four years have been
all about gritty realistic modern
warfare brick ah ah ah burn out dr. nerd
on you know deep base growling and
whatnot but I mean yeah you gotta have
some imagination to your games and I
mean like this is like for all of its
flaws completely original an awesome
story I mean I'm like there are some
inspirations obviously as with anything
but all right so I'm off to the greeley
which I was just at if I'd have known
that I could have compounded the
optional mission I would have done it
before but whoa hey whatever breath at
least I can go back here and open that
torque bar room still a really pretty
sight and you
like utilize this is it hey you wanted
an engine here you go who the hell is
that guy well hello [ __ ]
just like our plan how about ways to
sulfate some of us just want to go home
alright
you're not gonna don't put all the lines
and service tubes but hell if I know how
to get it out of there I'll figure it
out
go get your equipment together so we can
tell it back to the repair Bay hello
wait where am I going oh I'm going there
what
I guess I'm oh I might be entering on a
completely different part of this plank
yeah let me know I'm good on here I'll
save that for when I really need it okay
where am I going here oriented ground I
guess that means the planet oh I see oh
we're just going for the engine we're
not going for the ship itself oh okay
oh is that the guy I think I see him
yeah let you know you're kind of safe
out here bro I don't know what you're so
worried about all right aim and grab
Kinesis what did something just hit me
or what the hell just happened I'm gonna
run out of air here if I don't hurry up
I'm not sure what whoa who the [ __ ] is
hitting me all right
oh you Jesus you got some accurate aim
but so do I you a-hole
oh there's two of you now really it's
two of you now I'm gonna run out of air
well there's another there just keep
gonna popping out really I gotta grab
some air Jack just got to get some ban
they just popping out nowhere okay what
am i doing I'll just keep moving so that
I can stay away from them come on come
on come on I need air sunni or soon i'll
give me that Wow
[ __ ] you think you can handle it from
here yeah Clark I'm not an idiot and be
sure to lock the injectors down tight I
don't want them popping off in
mid-flight [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] that guy
he's gonna die a horrible death by now
I got the engine is everything ready
well not quite I need air
we're gonna go toss around like a [ __ ]
of the circus if we try to navigate that
atmosphere without a flight plan
what about using flight recorders from
these derelict ships Yeah right we could
reconstruct one of the routes they used
okay side the Roanoke look for small
Sonos before solar panel shaking out the
satellites with solar panels got it what
about this one right here wait what am I
looking for all right whatever
obviously it's not here so I need to go
down to the Roanoke which if I'm not
mistaken is the original ship they were
on before it's open these supply crates
AMRO can always use some more ammo all
right so we're off again I still have to
reiterate how cool it is the fact that
I'm flying around space like this is
like my dream like ah as a kid I wanted
to be an astronaut not that much but I
mean how cool is it just to be able to
fly around space I wish I could spend
more time here and when I play through
it a second time on my own I'm
definitely gonna spend a lot more time
exploring all the nooks and crannies
because I bet I bet there's tons of
Secrets I still want to know who the
hell that guy is must be another one of
the survivors from the ship that were in
the big floating box it was spinning
around space
it's any secret in here I mean I'm
surprised
Isaac spent holding his madness pretty
well I mean you could see how disturbed
he was in dead space - but I guess yeah
there was a lot of time in-between dead
space 2 & 3 for him to collect himself I
mean obviously his mind is still a
little broken but he seems to be holding
himself together pretty well there was
is that one episode where he saw the
riding on the walls I'm sorry this is
stuff stuck in my throat that's why I
was telling you about it we're getting
this alright anyway I'm just about
running out of time so I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna close shop right here in
this nice scenic view and pick it up
right away so I appreciate you all being
here thank you so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos
that I've done stick around the second
part I'm trying to aiming to get apart a
dead space 3 out every single day so
stick around it'll be here soon so thank
you again and as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye